I played Warcraft 3 just a little bit I
don't remember it looking this good
this was the beginning of like those
projects that were aware of stuff is
really heavy so what are some tricks you
guys use to be able to render shots with
like that many zombies zbrush really has
allowed an entire new generation of
character modelers to just Thrive we're
looking at the Halo 2 remastered in
cinematics which boy you guys knocked it
out of the park on this one it's like
you thought you knew what Halo was
supposed to look like this is what Halo
actually looks like
foreign
welcome back to another great episode of
VFX RS react this is a very special one
we've been wanting to react to game
cinematics forever and we are joined by
one of the best possible guests for this
this is Jerome Don Shaw also known as
Jed he's the supervising creative
director for love death and robots at
blur Studio I've been working at blur
studio for 20 years I started as a
character modeler and then I moved to
lighting rendering then started
supervising shows well I can't wait to
jump in on some of this history of game
Cinema here from stuff from like way
back to Warcraft 3 all the way to now
moving on to this episode forever so I
get to finally do it and with like
probably one of the best guests we could
probably do it with so yeah let's jump
in
man I remember the warcraft cinematics
when they came out way back in the day I
played Warcraft 3 just a little bit I
don't remember it looking this good
maybe it was because I was on a tiny
monitor there's been so many jokes about
the pre-rendered cut scenes you know
that's just been a whole Topic in gaming
forever which is like hey is this
rendered in engine or is this like
something else or like are you cheating
Us by that but like ultimately when
you're playing a game and you get to see
something like this it's kind of okay
when the actual game itself doesn't look
that good because this just kind of like
hyped you up for the vibe of it and
helps get the image in your mind of of
like what you're playing so yeah and it
was a reward you know like it was like
little treats after like you passed like
five missions then you'd get the
cutscene Heroes arise to challenge fate
and Lead their Brethren to battle
this one is from blizzard and this one
was like a huge inspiration at the time
because it looked attainable but it was
so well done and it was just so epic I
mean these were mini movies and they had
like great characters and they looked
like badass and I mean who did not want
to work on the shot like this but then
you know you know like I think that's
that's one thing about the game
cinematics like you can almost tell what
year they came out just by looking at
them but at the time to be able to do
something like this was just like
everybody wanted to be a part of that oh
you got armies did you see the hair
physics yeah you have dust you got bugs
you got water on the lens in that last
shot yeah the guy just like points at
the and I was like oh man I wish I could
have come up with that [ __ ]
yeah when you look at this this
animation though what's some stuff that
you see that's missing where you're like
now like technology that you would
almost take for granted what are the
things that are missing in these renders
everything just feels very very flat the
metals just feel like a little a little
doll you know the grass definitely could
have a little extra spec now all the
shaders have evolved so much like now
especially like these close-up shots of
the York at the end you can see that
there was no skin Shader at the time I
had like one Shader and you're like okay
well I'm gonna try to like make it a
little you know and you only had like
specular highlights you didn't have
Reflections or Reflections at the time
yeah it's funny like looking at it's
like the Rocks kind of look like the
same surface shininess as the grass is
the kind of same sort of shininess it's
the metal and like yeah really all you
can change like the color and like the
specular and so nowadays you can render
Reflections and that's what specular
highlights were attempting to mimic
except a specular highlight was just the
bright white Shine from a singular light
source it was very easy to calculate it
is a great way of Faking Reflections
because when you look at things like my
Apple watch here you really just feel
like you kind of see the shiny bits from
like the lights reflecting on it I mean
those are actually Reflections there's
more than just the shiny bright white
highlights but if you just had a little
soft white dot well you know that's easy
enough to move around on the surface and
do a little angle measurement and yeah
when you look at this that's where you
see everything as just white Shines on
it because that's how they're getting
things to look shiny since you're not
doing actual Reflections and all the
specular highlights they were around
but they were already faking like some
caustics inside the eyes it's pretty
it's pretty cool there's actually kind
of like that shading around the iris oh
yeah on the other side of the iris it's
like bright it's like probably the most
complicated Shader in the entire piece
yeah or it's just an artist sitting down
being like well I'm gonna literally
paint this side to be brighter because
that's how I know that that's what it
should look like because this is very
much like back in the day it's like you
don't get there by just physically
simulating light you get there by an
artist going I know how light works I'm
going to do my shortcuts and tricks to
get that look so you can kind of see
like the limits of it like when you look
at it like 20 years later but still like
I I feel like this one still holds up
pretty well
Warhammer yes Warhammer 40K oh now the
smoke is looking like volumetric let's
date this what when is this from what
what I think this one is
oh my God if I remember correctly Tim
was outside at the lunch table and he
was like man I had to pass on this
Warhammer cinematic today because you
know the schedule was too aggressive and
Dave Wilson who was one of the
supervisors who started like within two
weeks of me just looked at him was like
what do you mean like what's wrong with
you
no dude really they need like that
cinematic in three weeks and they was
like
so what like let's do it let's do it I
mean it was like a military uh operation
to deliver this thing in three weeks but
they did it
as much as like things have changed
since this was made there's still like
the the raw energy of like all right
we're animating this we're doing
compositions we're like setting up
different particle effects and it's like
yeah maybe like renderings a little
faster and simulating things are a
little bit faster but like just the
volume of action and movement and shots
doing this in three weeks today it's
just as hard you can stop on a lot of
frames and then there's just like little
funny like animation you know like funny
faces like from the zorks I mean it was
it was a fun time because there was
there was just so much energy and just
so much like you know it's like the
Brotherhood yeah
[Music]
that one was a cinematic device
supervised that team directed and that
we did for E3 in 2005 there's so much
[ __ ]
this was the first project where we were
using HDR lighting and Reflections and
we were rendering open exrs and it was
just like every day we're like my God
look at how good it looks hdrs was such
a revolutionary thing for 3D and it just
you look at the armor here you know this
is not just white circles like you have
gold Reflections and blue Reflections
and different shapes because now you're
sampling basically a 360 degree image
and pulling from whatever you want on
that image to like you know make a
reflection versus just a single white
circle that gets placed on things but
yeah HDR was just one of those things
where suddenly you could take a step
closer to reality and you're like oh we
might actually get there we might
actually be able to make things photo
real and physically accurate we thought
it was photoreal at the time
I was like well I don't know I don't
know how we're gonna top this one
because this is just just like
[Music]
and everybody was responsible for a
sequence it was one person responsible
for that whole sequence I feel like
we're coming back to that like we're not
there yet but I feel like we're
returning this era of one artist makes a
shot you know it's not like okay well I
need my mocap team I need my character
model he was like no like I have a
vision for a shot I'll make the shot
a shot like this was insane at the time
to just see like the amount of zombies
in there so what are some tricks you
guys use to be able to render shots with
like that many zombies we'll try to
render them all and then
[Music]
it's probably not gonna work so so then
like in this case it's probably
rendering like quadrants you know like
so he'll like they'll try to render half
see what it is it's still not working
for a quarter you know and then just
kind of put them all back together in
comp but there's some projects where it
just wouldn't render so we'd like render
them on cards and then just put cards
and if you pause on that one there's one
head on that monster that is Tim
Miller's head oh really that the
modelers
[Laughter]
nice and then he dies a horrible death
[Music]
war is everywhere the dwarves fight a
desperate battle against the Savage
green skins there's just so much to do
on this one but felt like by then we had
found like our style a little bit more
we had to fake so much stuff to just
kind of suggest this massive Army
up
that's the last character I've ever
modeled really right there yeah that was
when the zbrush came out what an
industry changing tool that was yeah
tell us about zbrush what did zbrush do
for you well zbrush allows you to
approach your model like it's Clay and
you can approach it as if you were a
sculptor and you can do something
without having to worry too much at
first about whether you're gonna have
enough definition enough polygons for it
before that if you wanted to model that
girl's chainmail for example every
single like piece had to be modeled and
then duplicated and if it was not enough
definition then you had to start over so
like that guy for example like the armor
transforms into that that kind of
clothing before that to model something
like this you had to have like enough
definition you had to extrude polygons
but you couldn't do too much because
then you can rig it it would be too
heavy so it was really complicated to do
this kind of really organic kind of
weird models before and zbrush really
has allowed a an entire new generation
of care to modelers to just Thrive
because they're good artists and they're
good sculptor so it's really liberated
like a lot of amazing artists yeah it's
like I need more like I need more
polygons here so I can like make fire
details like hit a button and just sub
devise like okay I'm good now and then
of course you can tag your zbrush model
which is you know super high details
it's got all your fine detail you
painted into it and maybe you don't
necessarily need to export as polygons
then you can start exporting it as
displacement Maps or normal Maps or what
Maps yeah and so you start like from
that point on you start to see like a
little bit more detail on the faces in
particular and you start to see like
some monsters that just feel much more
detailed and you know just feels more
more Rich you've seen the studies
animations the one guy doing the all the
Warhammer animations on his own yeah
yeah
foreign
at like these directors that have this
passion of like just showing that little
project you know and they'll do
everything themselves and they have to
be Scrappy because like when you have
limited budget and limited resources
that's when you have to be like really
creative then you gotta go around like
you know a system to do it and um kudos
to that guy man because yeah it's a lot
of work to do all this and finish it to
the level that he finished it like it's
a work of passion and I yeah we all saw
it like at work when it came out we're
like Jesus
when you guys at blur see something like
this do you reach out to the artist be
like hey like we should know each other
or you just kind of let it be yeah well
I mean we'll always try if they want to
come and work with us then great but we
also want to Foster the community aspect
of things where just tell us like you
know next time you have a project we'd
love to see it and you know next time
you're in town like come and check us
out we'll have something to gain when
it's a community of like-minded
storytellers because one day this guy
will direct a feature film you know and
even if it's not with us then we'll be
super happy to see him succeed
oh shoot uh time to subscribe
wow well done a new Twist on an old
classic yeah
laughs
so this one is the third one in the
trilogy of cinematics that we did for
Elder Scrolls online and this one was
kind of like a little bit of a I mean
for me personally not the end of an era
but that was like the culmination of
like the first 10 years Adler
that battle scene was crazy
there's just so many people that we can
do it this was the beginning of like
those projects that were where stuff is
really heavy because now we can render
hair properly so let's render her hair
that we can render like perfect
Reflections like and it's physically
correct we can do like a little bit of
crowds and have like 15 people like run
towards all right let's put them all in
and then all that stuff just kind of
adds up to like craziness what would you
say is like the blur look you know there
was a point where like people would talk
to us about the blur look which made us
like a little
a little anxious because we've always
tried to do like a lot of different
styles but I think this would be
probably the closest to the blur look at
least at that era characters that were
almost for real but not quite there yet
like in the official animation like this
one is 25 minutes of characters looking
pretty cool but it's not like a single
line of dialogue so that the help I love
this project so I just love the
direction I love the the universe of it
and how we approached it and these
characters man so now we're gonna look
at some cinematics that people have
mentioned a ton in comments by the way
he wants to take a look at something on
the show leave a comment down below with
your suggestion but we're looking at the
Halo 2 remastered cinematics which boy
you guys knocked it out of the park on
this one it's like you thought you knew
what Halo was supposed to look like this
is what Halo actually looks like
slip space ruptures directly off our
battle cluster show me this is a lot of
stuff you guys have to make though this
is like a full-on movies worth of
rendered shots every time I see a frame
of that project I still like my heart
still beats faster at the conversation
we had with Tim where he's like we're
gonna do the cinematics for a hill and
then he's like it's gonna be 50 minutes
in nine months
what we're like okay but the soul is not
going to be like lower quality because
it's just like no what are you talking
about
I remember being like but why but at the
same time like you know when the train
is gone is going down without the breaks
down the you know down the tracks I
still would like to have a little bit of
control so I was like okay well I'd love
to work on it
we split the supervising duties with the
with Kevin uh on that one but man it was
a military operation and the people that
we worked with like at Microsoft Book
Grade but it was an organization in the
growth of the studio that was a little
scary when sorry I guess yeah and that
was one of the probably like one of the
biggest legs okay we gotta have our [ __ ]
together yeah a lot of ways It's Not
Gonna Fly what was interesting about
this one is that it was for the 10-year
anniversary and it was going into the
game but we had to like match what they
had done with the cinematics like 10
years earlier
[Music]
God damn yeah bonkers
is this almost like too good in the
sense that like when you start playing
the game is it does it ruin your
experience because
the whole like debate of like some
people prefer just an entire like
real-time experience and not be taken
out of the game well for certain people
they like to have these pre-rendered
cinematics as like a little bit of a
treat in between missions oh absolutely
no I'm not critiquing your work at all
I just it frightens me of how good it is
but to be fair when they release that
Halo 10-year anniversary game the
graphics were also like making a huge
jump yeah and it was mind-blowing too
like it was it was it was crazy I have a
question for you guys okay so they hired
Master Chief's identity in the games
whatever he takes off his helmet it
always like pans away so my question is
what did you guys have under his helmet
well we know who Master Chief is because
we just like pull up the helmet off and
we just click the little eyeball next to
me it hides it so just like there's no
teapot under that helmet or something
or a tinier mask well they did do like
somebody hacked the original Halo one at
the endings going to take his helmet off
so to keep the camera there it's just
another helmet
so the cinematics for the game there's
moments of like photo realism in there
but then when then you actually play the
game in between the cutscenes the visual
Fidelity there's like a huge gap there
but in the most recent Modern Warfare
game so you guys did the cinematics for
that the game itself happens to just be
good enough so when the cutscenes hit
like yes they're Ultra cinematic but
then when you go into gameplay it's good
enough where it's like it doesn't feel
like you're getting a loss of quality
still so it's a little bit more seamless
in a way
what is your message from Captain Price
this stuff is like the one that's like
really really eye-catching the moments
you're like yeah this is totally real
this is the collaboration of the
supervisors of the layout team like with
the camera work it's the camera work
that you would use on the real live
action shoot yeah and same with the
lighting it's using the exact same
techniques that you would use on a live
action shoe I noticed on that shot where
the sun goes behind him you have
halation on the edges of him which is
pretty much an emulation of how real
cameras work and you know when you're
rendering a CG scene it's like there's
no such thing as like a sensor being
overblown or you know uh finger smear on
the lens causing things to bloom out in
a weird way and so you guys are clearly
starting to emulate how a real camera
works as well as the imperfections of
that to achieve a bit of a photo realism
all right
this is really the combination of like
almost 20 years of blur just trying to
kind of get better it shows the road
that we traveled what blur did on this
one this is the state of like what a
studio can do on game cinematics and by
extension on love doesn't robots this
kind of cinematics just becomes this
like super Productions now because it
requires everything to be a at such a
top level and it requires such huge
teams that it's very different approach
than what we used to do like you know 20
years ago what's the hardest thing to do
right now in CGI what's the next
advancement you're looking for I still
think like hair there's still some stuff
that at least for the type of software
that's mostly like off the shelf that
we're using in game cinematics and then
after that it's just rendering more
stuff but you know like real-time
rendering is also another venue that
we're really looking at now because
obviously it allows the directors to
approach this kind of projects like much
differently because now you can make
lighting decisions much earlier on and
then you can change stuff and not have
to wait weeks or months before you see
the results of like a bad decision yeah
engines like unreal are at a point now
where you can get that kind of fidelity
you might still have to cheat a few
things but it's almost there and the
fact that it's real time or you know
almost as opposed to like some of those
frames take five six ten hours you know
and it's um and it's expensive
we are going to be getting rid of every
single piece of merch in our store we're
gonna be playing a little bit of a game
to make this happen you see starting
right now there's a sale going on and
every single week items are going to be
getting cheaper and cheaper but of
course every single week the store is
going to get emptier and emptier so if
you're looking for a deal you gotta pick
just the right time to jump in here's
how this is going to work so starting
today everything is 15 off then starting
October 31st everything in the store
will be 25 off
that's nothing starting November 14th it
goes to 40 off I'm out
starting November 21st everything will
be 50 off but that's not all
and starting on Cyber Monday November
28th everything will be 75 off quarter
digital.com subscribers get an
additional 15 off at any point so they
wait all the way to the end they're
getting 90 off man what a great time to
be a quarter digital.com subscriber wait
Nico if we're going to be offering
things at 90 off why don't I just wait
until Cyber Monday if I need to make
things cost one penny for them to sell I
will but the thing is they'll probably
sell before that you wait too long you
might miss it and once they're gone
they're gone for good we're
reapproaching how we're doing merch next
year entirely so if you like any of
these designs it's your last chance yeah
that makes sense okay okay
so if you're interested in getting the
best deals that we've ever offered head
on over to Corridor Digital Dot store
before these items are gone for good it
was so great sitting down with you to
actually take a look at some of like the
coolest most inspiring animations that
I've seen over like the last 15 years to
say that they're just like you know
cinematics for a game is I feel like a
really reductive way to think about this
because this is like stuff that is
inspiring for like generations of
artists as well the competition that
like you had with other Studios is like
also propelling so many individuals out
there so thank you for helping make all
these thank you guys for having me ah
and I hope that it inspires like you
know a new generation of uh storytellers
or or just visual artists to uh to do
that Medium it's a it's a fun gig yeah
yeah
sweet well thank you so much thanks
thank you see you guys in the next one